***
Mit "Glass Onion"
freuen wir uns aktuell,
dass der 2. Teil
von "Knives Out" raus ist.
Wieder muss Detektiv Benoit Blanc
ein Netz aus Lügen entwirren.
(Blanc) This is not a game.
Aber wie macht er das?
Woran erkennt Benoit Blanc,
dass sein Gegenüber lügt?
Ist das überhaupt realistisch?
Tag, Jack Pop hier.
Unter den Detektiven ist Benoit Blanc
schon ein speziellerer Typ.
Aber ich fand es geil,
wie er in "Knives Out"
das Lügengebäude der Familie Thrombey
aufgelöst hat.
Wie er das genau macht,
schauen wir uns gleich an.
Zunächst wollen wir
ein Wrap-up zu "Knives Out" haben.
Für die, die den Film
noch nicht gesehen haben.
Und das macht für uns Robert Hofmann.
Hi, Robert.
Hey, Jack.
Benoit Blanc ist der letzte
richtige Gentleman-Schnüffler.
In "Knives Out"
versucht er rauszufinden,
wer den erfolgreichen Krimiautoren
Harlan Thrombey
auf dem Gewissen hat.
Zunächst scheinen alle
ein sehr gutes Verhältnis
zu Harlan gehabt zu haben.
We had that
secret wave communicating.
Ist's like he putting
his hand on my shoulder.
He is a genuinely selfless man.
Aber nach und nach kristallisieren
sich verschiedene Motive heraus.
Besonders hilfreich dabei für Benoit
wird Harlans Pflegerin Marta,
die sich immer übergeben muss,
wenn sie lügt.
*Sie erbricht sich.*
Und sie weiß als Einzige,
was tatsächlich geschehen ist.
Das glaubt sie zumindest.
Denn in Wirklichkeit ist alles
doch sehr viel komplizierter.
Und nur Benoit Blanc
hat den wirklichen Durchblick.
It is not an donut hole.
But a smaller donut
with its own hole.
And our donut is not whole at all.
Um zu erkennen, dass in dem Donut
noch ein kleinerer Donut steckt,
muss Blanc
bestimmte Skills anwenden.
Und welche das sind,
schauen wir uns jetzt an
gemeinsam
mit der Psychologin Mareike Thomas.
Mareike ist mittlerweile die
Psychologin unseres Vertrauens.
Zum 3. Mal ist sie
bei "Science vs. Fiction" dabei.
Beruflich beschäftigt sie sich viel
mit dem Regulieren von Emotionen.
Und das
spielt beim Lügen eine große Rolle.
Mareike, schön, dass du da bist.
Ich freue mich auch, danke.
Wir haben hier
schon über Joe Goldberg
aus der Serie "You" gesprochen.
Damals sind wir tief ins Thema
psychische Störungen eingetaucht.
Heute wird es ein bisschen
alltäglicher, es geht ums Lügen.
Aber nicht so um Notlügen, die wir
vielleicht jeden Tag selber machen.
Es geht um richtige Falschaussagen
in einem Mordfall.
Die wollen wir enttarnen.
Das ist gar nicht einfach.
Obwohl die meisten Menschen
ganz gute Lügner sein können,
sind die allermeisten tatsächlich
schlechte Lügen-Detektoren.
In der Forschung hat das angefangen
mit dem US-Psychologen Paul Ekman.
Der hat sich als Erster
im großen Stil
mit beobachtbaren Indizien
für Lügen beschäftigt.
Wann war das?
Das war sogar schon
in den 60er-/70er-Jahren.
Seine Grundidee war es dabei,
dass Emotionen, die eigentlich
verborgen bleiben sollen,
durch Mimik oder Bewegungen
quasi verraten werden.
Sein Paradebeispiel
sind die "micro expressions".
Stell dir das so vor:
Du möchtest eine bestimmte Emotion
vorspielen.
Die ist mit einem gewissen
Gesichtsausdruck verknüpft.
Der entgleist dir aber kurz vorher.
Das Ganze dauert
nur eine viertel bis halbe Sekunde.
Das ist auch der Grund,
warum das für ungeübte Beobachter
so schwer wahrnehmbar ist.
Paul Ekman
hat dafür dieses Beispiel.
Es ist eigentlich der
gleiche Gesichtsausdruck,
nur dass
diese micro expression durchbricht.
Entscheidend ist,
dass das unkontrolliert passiert.
Verstehe.
Ein sehr guter Beobachter,
der das auch trainiert hat,
der kann, wenn er sich auf diese
micro expressions konzentriert,
ein Indiz dafür bekommen,
dass eine Person lügt.
Das behauptet Ekman zumindest.
Dann versuchen wir mal,
das auf den Film anzuwenden.
Denn wir haben den großen Vorteil,
dass wir alle Szenen,
in denen offensichtlich gelogen wird,
beliebig oft abspielen können.
Etwa diese hier.
We had
a buisness discussion about e-books.
Wir können die langsamer machen,
und das haben wir auch gemacht.
Wir haben sie uns allesamt
Bild für Bild angeschaut.
Und was soll ich sagen?
Selbst wenn wir das machen,
ist es super schwer, eine von
diesen micro expressions zu finden.
Ekman sagt sogar selbst,
dass diese micro expressions,
in denen versteckte Gefühle
durchsickern, sehr selten vorkommen.
Eine der wenigen Studien,
die sich Ekmans Theorie
mal unabhängig angeschaut haben,
stammt aus dem Jahr 2008.
Die Versuchspersonen
sollten angesichts von traurigen,
beängstigenden
oder auch fröhlichen Bildern
ihre wahren Gefühle verbergen.
Micro expressions waren nur auf
2% aller Momentaufnahmen zu sehen.
Und dummerweise sogar dann,
wenn sie
ihre wahren Gefühle gezeigt haben.
Du siehst also,
die Studienlage ist recht dünn.
Es gibt kaum handfeste Beweise.
Deshalb werden die micro expressions
eher den Pseudowissenschaften
zugeordnet.
Auch wenn die micro expressions
heute umstritten sind,
hat Ekman trotzdem
einen sehr wichtigen Beitrag
zur Emotionsforschung geleistet.
Er hat herausgefunden,
dass wir Menschen
über 7 Grund-Emotionen verfügen.
Die zeigen sich
auch im Gesichtsausdruck.
Das sind Freude, Wut, Traurigkeit,
Furcht, Ekel,
Verachtung und Überraschung.
Diese sind
überall auf der Welt zu finden
und spielen beim Thema Lügen
auch eine wichtige Rolle.
Dann können wir ja wieder eine Szene
aus dem Film raussuchen,
wo jemand offensichtlich lügt.
Hier sagt Linda zu Marta,
dass sie sie sehr gern bei
der Beerdigung dabeigehabt hätte.
Ein Satz,
den wir von vielen
Familienmitgliedern hören.
*Sie sagt ihr, dass sie sie gern
auf der Beerdigung gehabt hätte.*
Genau, sie sagt es so,
als würde es ihr leidtun.
Das bedeutet, wir müssten sowas wie
Traurigkeit in ihrem Blick sehen.
Wie sieht aber
ihr Gesichtsausdruck für dich aus?
Auf jeden Fall nicht traurig.
Eher so ein bisschen schelmisch,
ja, und vielleicht auch
so ein bisschen mit Verachtung.
Die Mundwinkel und die Augenbrauen
sind oben.
Das passt nicht zur
eigentlichen Emotion Traurigkeit.
Das wäre ein Indiz für dich,
dass jemand lügt.
Laut Ekman wäre es das.
Er sagt, dass
bei gespielter Angst oder Trauer
die charakteristischen Falten
auf der Stirn oft fehlen.
Genauso,
wie bei einem gespielten Lächeln
die Augenmuskulatur
dann nicht mit beteiligt ist.
Diesen Erklärungsansatz
nennt man in der Lügenforschung
den kognitiven Ansatz.
Der besagt, dass unser Gehirn durch
das Lügen so beschäftigt ist
und ihm so viel abverlangt wird,
dass wir nicht alle Ebenen
kontrollieren können.
Dadurch passt dann oft das Gesagte
nicht zur Körpersprache.
Oder die Lebhaftigkeit wird
reduziert, wie in dieser Szene.
I still feel his hand
on my shoulder, passing the torch.
Walt erzählt emotional und gerührt
vom vertrauten Verhältnis
zu seinem Vater.
Aber schau mal in das Gesicht,
da passiert rein gar nichts.
Das finde ich ganz spannend,
weil das relativ unterschiedlich
zu sein scheint.
Wenn wir mal auf diese Szene schauen,
da wirkt Walt ja eher nervös.
*Walt antwortet unsicher,
verhaspelt sich.*
Das passt dann eher
zum 2. Erklärungsansatz,
den es in der Forschung gibt.
Der besagt, dass beim Lügen
die emotionale Erregung zunimmt.
Der Lügner weiß,
dass er etwas Verbotenes tut.
Er befürchtet vielleicht sogar,
erwischt zu werden.
Dadurch nimmt dann
die körperliche Erregung zu
und es häufen sich
auch Stresssymptome.
Das kennt man,
wenn Leute sich verhaspeln
oder man anfängt,
ganz stark zu schwitzen.
Oder wenn
man permanent schlucken muss,
so wie Joni in dieser Szene hier.
*Sie spricht oberflächlich
gelassen und beiläufig.*
Genau, ein anders Indiz ist auch,
wenn die Stimme
plötzlich höher klingt.
Das passiert oft,
wenn wir angespannt sind.
Das sieht man
hier bei Richard ganz gut.
*Seine Stimme geht nach oben.*
In der Lügenforschung
gibt es aber auch noch einen
genau gegensätzlichen Ansatz,
den der Kontrolltheorie.
Der besagt, dass Lügner zwar
angespannt sind, wenn sie lügen.
Aber sie tun alles, um verräterische
Anzeichen zu unterdrücken.
Ein guter Lügner würde also
sein Gegenüber vermehrt anschauen
oder besonders viel anlächeln,
um Vertrauen zu schaffen.
Dann lass hier mal kurz festhalten:
Ein Lügner ist entweder nervöser
oder unbeteiligter.
Er verhaspelt sich
oder ist besonders gut strukturiert.
Er versucht, auszuweichen,
oder gerade
irgendwie Vertrauen zu erwecken.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt sehr viele Theorien.
Fairerweise haben wir
nur 3 davon besprochen.
In der Sozialpsychologie
gibt es noch sehr viel mehr.
Wie um alles in der Welt
soll man dann rausfinden,
ob jemand lügt oder nicht?
Das ist ganz schön schwer.
Paul Ekman behauptet trotzdem
in seinem Buch "Telling Lies",
dass man in Laborexperimenten
Lügner anhand der Mimik
zu 80% identifizieren könnte.
80%, das ist krass.
Das ist nicht nur krass,
sondern auch vollkommen übertrieben.
Für diese Zahlen musste Ekman
auch ganz schön Kritik einstecken.
Vor allem deshalb, weil er selbst
nie eine Studie veröffentlicht hat,
die diese Zahlen belegt.
Laut aktueller Forschungsliteratur
liegen die Erfolgschancen,
eine Lüge nur anhand von
nonverbalen Anzeichen zu erkennen,
nicht über der von Zufallstreffern.
No!
- Yes.
Wenn wir fies sein wollen,
könnten wir sagen,
jemand anhand seiner Mimik als Lügner
oder Lügnerin zu entlarven,
das ist so gut wie würfeln.
Entweder es stimmt, oder eben nicht.
Vielleicht müssen wir
von Äußerlichkeiten weg
und uns mehr
auf den Inhalt konzentrieren.
Genau, Forscher gehen heute
davon aus, dass das Sprachliche,
was geäußert wird,
eher relevant ist.
Das kann man mit Befragungstechniken
auch eher hervorlocken
und vielleicht sogar verstärken.
Was wäre dann zum Beispiel ein
Anzeichen dafür, dass jemand lügt?
Eine Allgemeingültigkeit
ist nicht unbedingt gegeben,
weil sich
psychologische Laborexperimente
nur schwer in die Realität
übertragen lassen.
Das liegt daran, dass es nicht
unbedingt eine reale Interaktion
zwischen Fragendem
und Befragtem gibt.
Und daran, dass die Täuschung
ja auf Anweisung geschieht.
Es gibt aber
eine interessante Feldstudie
der University Of British Columbia.
Dort wurden Videoaufnahmen
von 78 Angehörigen analysiert.
Die hatten sich
an die Öffentlichkeit gewandt,
um vermisste Personen zu finden.
Allerdings war die Hälfte
dieser Angehörigen selbst schuldig,
diese Personen getötet zu haben.
Und deren Sprache hat sich
dann unterschieden von denen,
die nichts gemacht hatten,
unschuldig waren?
Ja, die Studie kam zu dem Ergebnis,
dass die Schuldigen
mehr als doppelt so viele vage
Formulierungen benutzt haben.
Sowas wie:
Die echten Apelle klangen hingegen
klarer und unmittelbarer.
Also vage Formulierungen.
Wir können mal reinschauen
in unsere Szenen von "Knives Out".
Diese hier hatten wir vorhin schon.
Da sagt sie, ich wollte,
dass du dabei bist,
aber ich wurde überstimmt.
Das ist ja nicht wirklich konkret.
Normalerweise würde man sagen,
der oder die war dagegen.
Dann gibt es noch
ein anderes Beispiel, diese Szene.
We talked, we had
a business discussion about e-books.
Jesus, there was nothing.
Hier bleibt Walt
ja auch eher unkonkret.
Und wir wissen ja,
dass er nicht die Wahrheit sagt.
Aber es gibt auch das Gegenteil.
Wenn Menschen
besonders gut lügen können,
erzählen sie ihre Geschichten
sehr ausgefeilt und detailreich.
Wie hier.
Harlan finally decided
to put his Mum in a nursing home.
Linda had always opposed that.
And I wanted to wait
until we got back to Boston
to tell her this to avoid a scene.
And Harlan wanted me
to tell her then.
That was it.
Bei Richard wissen wir, dass er
seine Frau seit Längerem anlügt.
Er hat auch
ganz schön was zu verlieren.
Seine Frau hat das Vermögen
und es gibt einen Ehevertrag.
Stimmt.
Das ist auch eine gute Frage.
Hängt der Erfolg der Lüge davon ab?
Also lüge ich krasser, wenn mehr
für mich auf dem Spiel steht?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt da ein interessantes
Experiment von Kristina Suchotzki.
Das ist die derzeit
aktivste deutsche Lügenforscherin.
Die hat ihren Probanden
Stromschläge angedroht,
sollte der Computer ihre Aussagen
als unwahr klassifizieren.
Obwohl das ethisch
ganz schön fragwürdig ist,
hat sich gezeigt,
was sich zeigen sollte.
Personen, die lügen, hatten generell
schon einen langsameren Puls
und schwitzigere Hände.
Das Ganze hat sich
durch die Androhung der Stromschläge
noch mal verstärkt.
Das heißt,
je mehr ich zu verlieren habe,
desto eher
wird man mir eine Lüge auch anmerken.
Vielleicht.
Denn je mehr du zu verlieren hast,
um so besser wirst du deine Lüge
voraussichtlich auch vorbreiten.
Und eine souveräne Lüge
ist oft auch glaubhafter
als eine gestotterte Wahrheit.
Bei Verhören werden deshalb
bestimmte Abläufe
immer mehrfach abgefragt.
Wenn der Befragte dann immer
denselben Wortlaut verwendet
oder 2 Befragte
immer die gleichen Ausdrücke.
Dann kann man davon ausgehen,
dass es sich um eine
einstudierte Geschichte handelt.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin,
dann scheint es so zu sein,
als gäbe es gar keinen richtigen Weg,
mit dem man Lügner erkennen kann.
Sagen wir es mal so, in
der Wissenschaft ist man sich einig,
dass Menschen ziemlich
schlechte Lügen-Detektoren sind.
Es gibt da
eine umfassende Meta-Analyse,
die 25.000 Datensätze
von Versuchspersonen untersucht hat.
Die Versuchspersonen sollten dabei
Lüge von Wahrheit unterscheiden.
Die Trefferquote
lag auch hier bei 54%.
Also auch nicht viel besser
als der Zufall.
Was allerdings spannend ist,
hat man sich ausschließlich
die Tonaufnahmen angehört,
lag die Trefferquote bei 63%.
Und damit höher
als bei dem Videomaterial.
Man könnte jetzt schlussfolgern,
dass uns das Bild vielleicht
sogar ein bisschen ablenkt.
Okay, aber 2/3 der Lügen
jetzt zu enttarnen,
finde ich schon sehr gut.
Vielleicht wäre das ein guter Hinweis
an alle, dann die Augen zu zu machen.
Das sehen wir bei Benoit Blanc nicht.
Der ist ja aber auch Detektiv,
der ist besonders geschult,
der hat Spezialwissen.
Also,
der hat anscheinend andere Methoden,
um diese irrelevanten Details
dann auszublenden.
Möglicherweise.
Allerdings muss man auch dazusagen,
die Meta-Studie hat auch gezeigt,
dass es keinen Unterschied macht,
ob man beruflich
mehr mit Lügen zu tun hat.
Sei es als Polizist,
Richter oder als Psychiater.
Die vermeintlichen Experten
schnitten nicht besser ab
als die Laien,
zumindest im Durchschnitt.
Aber es gibt Menschen, die Lügner
besonders gut erkennen können.
Und einer von denen ist Marco Löw.
Von dem habe ich
ein interessantes Interview gelesen.
Das ist
ein ehemaliger Verhörspezialist.
Der hat sich 5.000 seiner
eigenen Verhöre noch mal angeguckt,
hat die analysiert.
Dann hat er noch mal rekapituliert,
welche Erfolge und Misserfolge
er mit welcher Frage-Taktik
gehabt hat.
Und warum er
in bestimmten Situationen
auf die Lügen der betroffenen
Personen reingefallen ist.
Er hat sich die verbale
und die nonverbale Ebene angeschaut.
Er hat dann festgestellt,
es gibt immer wieder bestimmte Muster
im Aussageverhalten der Leute.
Was ich spannend fand, war,
dass er festgestellt hat,
man muss sich erstmal
so einen Nullwert anschauen.
Er nennt das Baseline.
Also wie ist die Person,
wenn die ganz normal und entspannt
dasitzt und spricht.
Und er hat dann geschaut,
wie die in diesen Lügensituationen
von diesem Nullwert abweichen,
von dieser Baseline.
Das klingt total sinnvoll.
Eben weil die persönlichen Anzeichen
so individuell sind.
Jetzt müssen wir aber sagen, das
sehen wir bei Benoit Blanc nicht.
Der betreibt ja
keinen Small-Talk mit der Familie.
Das stimmt,
aber der sitzt da ja immer mal rum
und hockt da auch einmal im Dunkeln.
Also, der beobachtet die schon,
kriegt da ja doch relativ viel mit.
Vielleicht reicht das ja auch schon.
I suspect ...
Über eine Person
haben wir noch gar nicht gesprochen,
nämlich über Ransom.
Der hat ja, Achtung Spoiler,
den krassesten Grund zu lügen.
Das stimmt, Ransom
macht das auch sehr geschickt.
Wie in dieser Szene.
This is a copy of just the header
of a toxicology report.
Da lügt er Marta eiskalt ins Gesicht
und lässt sich, wenn du mich fragst,
überhaupt nichts anmerken.
Da ist auch
so eine Art natürliche Grenze.
Es gibt Menschen, die vielleicht
schon psychopathische Züge haben
oder auch
an ihre eigene Geschichte glauben.
Die sind fast gar nicht
als Lügner zu enttarnen.
Da ist es gut,
dass Benoit Blanc Hilfe hat.
Nämlich von der Pflegerin Marta,
die wir grad gesehen haben.
Die hat eine sehr spezielle Gabe,
sie muss immer kotzen, wenn sie lügt.
Yes or no will do.
No.
Dear Girl, I'm sorry!
Das kannte ich
so spezifisch auch noch nicht.
Aber, to be fair,
Lügen ist für die meisten Menschen
unfassbarer Stress.
Man muss einerseits
die Wahrheit verheimlichen,
sich vielleicht
eine Alternativgeschichte ausdenken.
Dann seine eigentlichen Gefühle
unterdrücken.
Und dabei
möglichst authentisch wirken.
Dieser Stress kann dazu führen,
dass das enterische Nervensystem
aktiviert wird.
Das kann dann Symptome verursachen
wie Übelkeit, Reizdarm.
Oder, wer kennt es nicht,
vor Prüfungen zum Beispiel,
Stressdurchfall.
So weit hergeholt
ist Martas Reaktion also nicht.
Am Ende
ist es auch ihr und unser Glück.
Denn es wird nicht nur durch
Benoit Blanc der Fall aufgeklärt,
sondern damit
auch ihre Unschuld bewiesen.
*Blanc erklärt den Anwesenden, dass
Marta unschuldig war an Harlans Tod.*
If Harlan had listened to you
and called the ambulance
he would be alive today.
Ich bin jedenfalls gespannt, wie es
jetzt weitergeht in "Glass Onion".
Wie Benoit Blanc dort den Fall löst.
Damit ihr Lust auf den Film bekommt,
fasst uns Robert Hofmann
das Ganze noch mal zusammen.
Worauf dürfen wir uns
im neuen Film freuen?
Auch
"Glass Onion - A Knives Out Mystery"
beginnt erstmal ganz unverfänglich.
Der Tech-Milliardär Miles Bron lädt
wie jedes Jahr seine Freunde ein.
Diesmal
auf seine griechische Privat-Insel
für ein großes Krimi-Spiel.
Um herauszufinden, wer seinen
angeblichen Tod verursacht hat.
Doch dann
kommt es zu einem wirklichen Mord.
Und die Frage steht im Raum,
wer ist es gewesen?
Und nur Benoit Blanc kann
wahrscheinlich diesen Fall lösen.
Would you explain it to us than,
detective?
Was wir von "Glass Onion"
bis jetzt gesehen haben,
sieht echt gut aus,
das sollte man nicht verpassen.
Bei diesem wirklich starken Cast,
der tollen Kulisse
und einem
durchaus spannenden Regisseur.
When does the murder mystery start?
Oh my god!
Danke, Robert.
Wenn ihr mehr
von seinen Filmkritiken sehen wollt,
dann schaut in die Infobox
und zu Roberts Kanal.
Flitzt zu ihm und lasst
ein bisschen Liebe von uns da.
Dir vielen Dank fürs Erklären.
- Gerne.
Und wenn ihr keine Fälle, äh, Folgen,
von uns verpassen wollt,
dann vergesst nicht, diesen Kanal
zu abonnieren.
Und
die Glocke zu drücken.
Wiedersehen.
Tschüs.
Copyright MDR 2022
UT: Büschel
Ich habe "Glass Onion" noch
nicht gesehen, aber Robert.
Wenn ihr seine Filmkritik
sehen wollt, klickt hier oben.
Und hier unten findet ihr noch ganz
viel mehr psychologische Themen
in unserer Psycho-Playlist.